thank you
we need to measure performance and
availability for any cloud-based service
we build we also need to set the targets
so we know if our service meets
expectations or if we need to improve
its performance and availability
without measurements and targets we're
just guessing about where to spend our
efforts
another name for such a Target is a
service level objective or SLO an
example is a low might be that the
service should return good non-error
responses 99 of the time measured
monthly
let's say our service gets a million
requests per month that means we have an
error budget of 10 000 failures per
month
if we have had 5 000 failures in the
first few days of the month we're still
meeting RCL technically but the trend is
not great we need to know so we can fix
the service before we miss the objective
let's see how to set this up in Google
Cloud run
now I use cloudron for my containerized
workloads cloud run is serverless so I
don't have to configure or maintain
virtual machines or clusters Google does
all that for me
here is the cloud run page for a live
service that is receiving a couple of
thousand users per day the project
contains a single Cloud run service
here you can see the details of that
service
and here is the new SLO tab
let's click it there are no service
level objectives here yet so let's
create one availability and latency are
typical indicators that we'd like to
monitor this tool supports both you can
also Define custom indicators from here
by the way if you'd like to learn more
about the best practices for slos
there's a great chapter about it in
Google's free site reliability workbook
I really like that book because it
contains practical examples from Google
and Google customers like Evernote the
Home Depot the New York Times and others
in that book you can read about what
worked for them and what didn't I prefer
to learn from their mistakes instead of
making my own I'll drop a link to the
book in the video description below
anyway let's keep it simple and create
an availability objective and use the
default of request based
clicking continue
and here we see the successful requests
and errors for the last hour
clicking continue now it's time to set
the objective I think it's useful to
start with a loose expectation and
refine it as I learn more
let's say that every calendar month the
server should return a good response 99
of the time
clicking continue
then I click here to create the new SLO
all right
now the page shows our newly created SLO
here under service level indicator we
see the current fraction of successful
requests over the last half hour
here under error budget we see a red
line that is declining gently
the numbers above zero so we're still
meeting our solo of 99 good responses
what happens when the error budget hits
zero well this tool is smart enough to
tell if we're burning up our budget too
fast and it can alert us that way we'll
know before we run out of our budget and
miss our SLO
I'll click here to create an alert click
next pick Martin's cell phone so I get a
text message
and click next again
it can also send alerts to other
channels like pager Duty slack email
webhooks and Pub sub
but I personally prefer text message
alerts because I see them right away but
you should pick what's right for your
organization
here I can enter instructions that will
be sent with the alert when you run a
service for some time you start building
up a Playbook of common errors I know
that in the past latency has suffered
when I forgot to set main instances for
this particular Cloud run service
so I will enter reminder here in the
alert message to check that setting
okay we'll be notified if we're in
danger of missing our SLO
that is great because if we apply a bad
configuration or deploy slow code we
will know and can fix it hopefully
before angular users start calling us
but what if we miss our SLO
that is a very valuable signal and is
telling us to increase the priority of
reliability work
that will do two things first it will
reduce the rate of new features added to
the service which will increase
stability
second it will give us time to work on
improving availability and performance
for the service once we meet our SLO we
can prioritize new features again
any organization creating software
always has a difficult Choice should we
add new features to the service which
often hurts performance and availability
or should we improve its stability
if we make the wrong choice we will
waste resources
but slos tell us which activity to
prioritize
I want to show you one more cool thing
before we wrap up
I'll click the hamburger menu here
scroll down to monitoring
and pick services
here we see the cloud run service that
we just set up an sl04
if we have app engine apps or kubernetes
clusters in a project we can click here
to define a new service for them and
then Define slos
we can also create our own custom
service for databases virtual machines
networking and a few others
if we build a set of slos for our entire
service we can see them all here in this
dashboard and see which ones meet their
slos and which ones don't that gives us
a great bird's eye view of our services
now go Define some great slos and take
charge of your services availability and
performance your customers will
appreciate the clarity and you will
learn if you should focus on new feature
work or service stability
thank you for watching if you have any
questions about slos or if you have a
suggestion for a serverless topic for a
future episode please let me know below
I read every single comment until next
time
[Music]